jst me voilà en chair et en os vous
voyez bien que j'existe g existe et
c'est ce dont tous les théâtres rêve
depuis six mois maintenant
ici on répète deux fois par semaine
alors que la date de représentation
n'est bien sûr pas connu mais peu
importe pour les comédiens l'essentiel
est ailleurs
ça fait du bien parce que eh ben on
s'évade quand on vient répéter on
on imagine des histoires et on est un
petit peu comment dire dans un autre
monde et ça c'est très important le
monde de l'imaginaire et surtout avec le
compte du chat botté et donc on s'évade
on joue plein de personnages on met des
costumes c'est de l'amusement quoi une
programmation des affiches comme si de
rien n'était en temps normal c'est plus
de 200 représentations par an et une
vingtaine de spectacles dans ce théâtre
alors on se prépare à revenir à ce
rythme à tout moment tout peut arriver à
tout moment donc on se prépare toujours
quand même à la reprise perd prenantes
on doit pouvoir programmer si les choses
réagissaient rapidement
ça nous permet de garder le moral de
croire aux choses et puis de ne pas
oublier que les choses ont existé il ya
une petite pause et que des choses
reprend vont reprendre avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé et voilà la de
transformer une loge en chambre elles
sont normalement réservés aux artistes
mais avec des pertes de 10000 euros par
mois le directeur a mis en location ses
loges
ça permet de garder vivant le contact
des choses et puis de souvenirs aussi à
des frais qui eux se poursuivent
toujours
et donc de s'organiser de trouver des
petites terreurs astuces pour essayer de
garder la tête haute
hier les équilibres au total financiers
pour être en très bonne santé
dès la reprise à tous les niveaux pour
les comédiens il reste un autre espoir
que l'incontournable festival d'avignon
prévu en juillet puisse voir le jour